It is often believed that in relationships,
opposites attract.
Like two magnets compelled together by the
force of their opposite poles, two humans
are attracted into a bond of love and intimacy
when they are opposites of one another.
The point of a relationship is to have someone
to share life with.
Not only that, but someone to help navigate
through and improve life with.
Perhaps it is possible that opposites are
often believed to attract because they create
a dynamic exchange of personal improvement.
If a couple is to some level opposite of one
another, when each person brings their views
and personality to the table, they can provide
alternative insight and perspective into each
other’s lives.
A check-and-balance of sorts where the contrast
between each partner provides equilibrium
to each others’ personality type.
This is of great value because our personalities
can be very elusive and consuming.
After we have become attached and conditioned
by our personality at an early age, they tend
to run away with us.
We should appreciate and embrace our unique
personalities, but their force can often cause
us to become complacent and stagnant.
They can close us off from considering and
executing improvements in our self and our
life.
And therefore, it is very beneficial to have
someone who can help us consider and mediate
our personality from a different vantage point.
The likely truth is that a happy long-term
relationship forms out of a balance of being
both opposite and similar.
An elaborate mix of complementary and contrasting
personality traits and values, layered onto
one another in an order that provides balance
to both individuals.
But regardless of how true it is or isn’t
that opposites attract, there will always
be some level of difference in the personalities
and perspectives of two people.
And what’s more important than anything
else is both partners being aware of each
other’s differences and possessing the willingness
to work through them and meet in the middle.
For a relationship to survive where both individuals
feel inspired, challenged, and benefited,
each side must be willing to give up a little
bit of themselves in order to receive a little
bit from their partner.
To be open to the ways in which their partner
lives and the potential benefits it can have
on their life and the relationship as a whole.
It is this exchange that brings balance to
each person, neutralizes complacency, and
facilitates a relationship of lasting and
potent love.